it is Thanksgiving and almost next week
right and when I think of Thanksgiving
the only thing that matters to me truly
is pie so we are talking tips and trips
for take um tricks for making the
perfect pie crust Andrea McLean joining
us from Poppin pies you're the owner and
the chef and I've had full disclosure
I've had her pie before Oh my gosh I I
think it might be the best pie I've ever
had in my life so tell me what's the
trick here how could we do this like you
basically so I have my dough here sorry
to go it's already rolled out and it's
wow okay we're picking it up I like to
fold it in quarters
so and why just to make it easier to
make it easier there's a couple
different ways to do it but for me this
is like the easiest one okay so what I
do is I use I kind of Center it like
that all right center
pull it off to the side oh okay that's
perfect that way it's even yeah great
wow I mean I I almost expected it to
kind of fall apart but it doesn't it's
very um very sturdy yeah it really is
so now I just kind of took it into the
corners okay you just want to make sure
it's like all the way into the pie shell
oh got it okay so I and I always buy the
frozen pie shell so this is a big
difference for me this is and you could
totally do that too it still works with
this yeah well this is better okay and
this is gonna make it pretty because
it's going to give you that crimped gel
okay all right so then if you have a
little extra excess I usually cut it off
oh okay so if it's like hanging out on
the table it kind of just kind of you
just love the excess okay
so you just want to leave like an inch
and a half an inch and a half okay so
cut that so then while we're doing this
now your pies you're out of the Vegas
Test Kitchen tell folks where that is
yes it's downtown uh right next to
Ferguson's okay
um so I'm there from Thursdays through
Sundays I sell pies by the slice there I
sell uh great limited um selection of
Pies but I also do whole pies for
pre-order uh usually the best way to do
that is to just message me on Instagram
which is your handle is popping pies and
pies okay and email and you still are
taking orders but you're getting busy
it's getting tight it's getting it's
getting close I think by the end of
today I might okay maybe you heard it
here first if you want Thanksgiving pies
from Andrea at pop and pies you got to
get in on this really quickly
um okay so so we've got about a minute
left so show me what to do here we're
gonna wanna roll it oh so you want to
roll it tight oh okay so that's kind of
what I've been doing here got it okay
rolling it it kind of adds like a little
extra extra layered and a little more
flakiness to the crust
and okay while we're rolling what kind
of Pies do we have over here so we have
pumpkin classic pumpkin with candied
pumpkin seeds we have apple crumbles uh
chocolate peanut butter it's kind of my
signature pie at this point wow I got
pecan and I got salt and maple oh wow
okay I don't know if we have a we can
pull these up oh my gosh these look
absolutely Divine okay we're almost out
of time so tell me what left to do so
this is my little signature
um crimp so it's my little way of doing
it I kind of make little flower petals
with it so I just oh whoops and I
already okay this is why we leave it to
the professionals folks
it's still it's still beautiful okay
well we know it'll taste good because
Andrea made it thank you so much for
coming on the show this morning this is
fun I could do this and hopefully not
ruin it all day popping pies folks
that's where to go order those
Thanksgiving pies really quick maybe
look ahead to Christmas thank you so
much for coming on thank you for having
me today oh my goodness oh I can't wait
okay I gotta try one of those